[Music]
hello I am ju Antonio Bona and I am
director and writer
of the plain crash scene is a pivotal
moment in the film their lives change
forever we had long interviews with the
survivors each of them had a different
memory of what happened and basically
the idea was to do something very
immersive
[Applause]
[Music]
when
there is a very interesting change of
light in that sense that somehow marks
the change of the tone of the scene when
they get into the cloud right Pedro yeah
exactly because at the beginning um of
the scene we see them like having
fun and as the mechanic Rock explains
them how to cross the Andes the light
goes darker and Bluer and that's when it
it gets
[Music]
serious
technically this was a very complex uh
scene to shoot all the forces all the
physical forces that are exerted on our
characters are real we had a fuselage
mounted on a Gimbal and a long one you
know that moved that little bit and then
we had another gimbal that was like
moving really really
extremely there is an escalation in the
scene we start in the Sun and then we
get into the cloud and then we at the
very end we are able to go over the
cloud again and then we have this
blinding light which is very symbolic
for the character of Numa I had this
idea of finishing the escalation with
the
sunlight this is the first scene I start
working on I was inspired with the light
and of the photography we got this idea
of of using the sound of the engines
because B was telling me that we not
going to use Music one of the biggest
challenges that I find with scoring
films is um not just where to put music
but where not to have
music when you leave space for people it
allows them to truly feel something that
you really need for a scene like this
the scene has to be dramatic as well so
I realized that I had to find the sound
of the engine of this
f37 and it was something difficult to
find because they're not working anymore
so we have to do like research and find
twin turbo rollsroyce engine has an
engine like that to we record that so I
thought when when the light of the sun
burns the screen the sound is like so
high that kind of like became
silence that's the moment that we create
a silence and in that silence we do
something very interesting which is this
explosion
we talk to the survivors the worst part
of the accident was not the crash
against the mountain but once they slide
through the snow it's the crash against
the snow and it's how all the seats like
were pushed towards the
cockpit we call it the accordion uh and
actually it was the more challenging
part because that had to be designed
shot by shot and mixing a lot of
techniques it was super difficult to
visualize like which effects we had to
do and what was a damy and what was a
CGI the knees the everything breaking
and the face of oenia and this and that
and I was really really happy well happy
for the work that we did that everything
that we did it's on the
screen we showed all the backgrounds for
real so there is no CGI I was shooting
myself those plates on a helicopter we
were at 13,000 ft the wind was terrible
that day and I remember that we had to
cross the spot where the plane crashed
14 times it's based on on real
photography and we make hundreds and
thousands of Photography in order to
create all the backgrounds we had more
shots from the outside of the plane but
the more we were inside the fuselage the
more effective the scene was
uh actually to stay with the characters
which is basically one I general idea
for the film like to be very close from
the characters to stay with them uh all
the time the more we were into the plane
with them not knowing what was going on
the the
better so the Avalanche happened I think
it was the day
I should say that shooting this scene
was probably um one of the most
challenging things I've ever done in my
life because the set was so
limited
[Music]
the space that they end up having after
the avalan hits it's like you know 4
feet high by probably 10 12T long so
it's like a place that's really
[Applause]
small in that space we had to put 19
actors eight corpses and two camera crew
Bru a lot of these shots the ceiling is
digital because uh there was no other
way to see the scene we use fake bags so
they were like made of rubber so it was
safe for the actors rehears the scene a
couple of times so every everybody knew
exactly where to be what not to do in
order to be safe but again the same way
we did the plane crash very immersive
this is the we have the same concept in
here
it was the most demanding scene for the
actors probably this is the worst moment
for the actors because they had to be
under this kind of like wood platform
they had to be underneath in the dark
they had a layer of snow of like 20 cm
and we did very long takes in order to
keep the energy flowing all the time I
really hate when you cut the scene and
you need to reestablish the energy in
between takes so we bet for going for
very long
takes and actually one one of the
challenges and I think one of the things
that I'm most proud of is that you you
can barely see anything you don't see
actually the Avalanche it's uh all the
time inside the plane and it's all about
sound yeah now that you mention uh um
there's like this this trick about the
Avalanche is coming for the first time
like everybody's just clapping and
banging the musiz so we we mix the sound
of the Avalanche coming the vibrating
sounds of the metal that we use also on
the a on the plane crash
scene it's kind of like echo of that
sound so something danger again is
happening so it's this kind of sounds
that we listen on the first
scene the sounds are muted actually if
it was like some friction against the
microphones we bury microphones under
the snow we also record him like muffle
and then we get out so we decide to have
this realistic kind of like documentary
sound on each s has a different
sound one shot it's like more in silence
so you can you can hear more the scream
in next shot you hear more the
wind you hear different kind of like
lower frequencies higher frequency so we
have this dynamic range to make like the
Rhythm and less aggressive somehow
remember that there was a whole
choreography where they had to come out
to the surface they had a number and we
were like saying number one number two
number three and as as they are coming
out they are helping each others to come
out yeah we have to remember that this
all of this is real snow the special
effects steam was bringing from Mountain
and uh can see the skin against the the
snow it's it's tremendous they were
really cold and you can see the amount
of effort that the actors did of panic
the way they emerge from the dark to
Crossing this layer of
snow anytime you're working on a film
you want to make sure that the music you
write is telling the correct
story uh it just so happened that this
time we were working on something that
was rooted in real life rooted in truth
rooted in an event that happened to
actual people so I was constantly
thinking about the people whose lives
were tragically altered that that one
day in the
Andes I just wanted to be with them hold
space for them as I was writing
throughout the entire process
[Music]
I really want to talk about the makeup
is extraordinary yeah that that is one
thing that I wanted to say you know
about the makeup team because all work
obviously it shows a lot because you
know I'm seeing all these faces in such
a closeup it was really difficult for
the makeup uh Team to work with this
these makeups because obviously you know
Pedro was doing this kind of Photography
that you don't really really know what
you are doing until you don't see there
and then you want to retouch but you
cannot get into there to retouch the
makeup but still it looks like amazing I
mean all the layers of the makeup you
know that's telling the story of the
faces because you can see them you know
going from the day one to 72 as you can
tell by the how the skin is burned by
the sun you can start to see how they
are losing weight gradually see how they
are losing the meat on their faces
especially now the textures on the faces
are
incredible so I had this idea of this
moment when they come out to the surface
it's the mtin giving birth to the
society because it's right after this
moment that the the Society of the snow
exist is is the moment that the the
society is
[Music]
[Applause]
created